- This looks like the
best taste test ever,
cause they just asked
what my favorite food was
and I told them,
and now I got it.
What the (bleep) is that?
(heavy instrumental music)
- I've got ramen, fresh fruit, horchata.
(bleep) fusion, bruh.
This actually might not be that bad.
"Ramchata," it's a "ramchata."
Ramen and horchata together at last.
Get in there.
Smells delicious.
I'm blaming the strawberries
and the peaches.
Is it weird how excited I am about this?
I think this is gonna
actually taste great.
Let's see.
(heavy instrumental music)
No.
(coughs)
There's little chunks
of mealy ramen in here.
(bleep) devil's cocktail.
Nine different things stuck
in my teeth right now.
That's the grossest
combination you can make.
It smells so good though.
- It just smells like donuts and cheese.
Why are you doing this to me?
(blending)
That's a terrible color.
The chips don't really blend well.
It's kind of just like a
bunch of soggy chip crumbs.
Surprisingly, not that disgusting.
Kinda sweet and light and not that bad.
I'm blown away.
The burnt TV dinner,
that's what we'll call it.
Cause that's what it tastes like.
I mean, I wouldn't make it,
cause why would I put
these things in a shake?
- Mashed potatoes, beer, chicken,
shrimp and cocktail sauce.
None of this is gonna be good.
Everybody knows, once you vomit a food,
you never want to eat that food again.
This is gonna taste like vomit.
I don't want this to ruin my life.
Let's do it.
(blending)
This is as white as me.
It smells like, um.
(gagging)
A little bit like a chowder.
I was trying to keep it under my tongue
so I didn't taste it.
It moves like wet sand.
The more I smell it,
the less I'm revolted by it.
Now I'm starting to think
I would like it if it was warm.
(beep)
Almost palatable.
- We got some brie.
Some sweet potato, which I love.
Broccoli.
Kale.
This one might be good without the cheese.
(blending and screaming)
It's real bad.
First of all, it's warm from the tea.
These little guys on the broccoli,
they don't blend.
And then the cheese comes in again.
It's turning back to solid.
This is vomit.
I think the name for it is vomit.
- In theory, it should
taste like awesomeness.
But, I don't know.
Let me talk myself.
Do it, do it.
(blending)
Everything that has artificial pizza
has like one smell,
and it has that same smell.
In honor of it looking like baby food,
I'm gonna airplane it.
(airplane motor)
I'm so scared.
I'm terrified.
You've put much weirder
things in your mouth before.
That's actually really good.
A pizza smoothie.
This here, this is eatin'.
If it was warmed up, I'm telling you,
I would take this all down.
It's like baby food.
(train)
If you want your baby to have
childhood diabetes.
(blending)
Can I take this?
This is not bad.